on savait depuis près de deux semaines
que la mise en examen et et j'allais
dire au bout du chemin
elle est acté aujourd'hui c'est
l'aboutissement d'une séquence qui au
fond a empêché le déroulement normal de
la campagne électorale qui est un
dialogue entre des candidats et les
français françois fillon a pris une
décision de s'en remettre au suffrage
universel la décision du peuple avide
ailleurs à l'espèce oui mais je pense
que il là et je le soutiens dans cette
démarche parce que aujourd'hui à cinq
semaines de l'élection ou un peu plus
et bien la compacte va reprendre ses
droits
et puis les françaises détermineront ils
choisiront et il se choisiront le projet
et le projet françois villon
c'est le seul qui puisse permettre de
redresser le pays alors le projet on va
beaucoup en parler encore de cette
émission mais est ce que vous estimez
que le calendrier judiciaire a été
précipitée c'est le mot qui a utilisé un
françois fillon dans sa déclaration
écrite devant les juges est ce que vous
contestez
le calendrier judiciaire écoutez c'est à
l'autorité de justice de conduire le
calendrier qu'elle entend qu'elle entend
mener pour ma part mais ce que je
souhaite pathos et chrome dans une
véritable sérénité de la justice
en effet je n'ai entendu personne
personne je parle des autorités
aujourd'hui de l'exécutif par exemple
s'émouvoir de la disparition totale du
secret de l'instruction
on retrouve une partie des procès
verbaux tendent à presse quotidienne
dans la presse hebdomadaire et repas
tous les procès verbaux surtout ceux à
charge
je crois que la présomption d'innocence
j'ai le souvenir du débat ici
le rapporteur était michel
dreyfus-schmidt où nous parlions au
moment du nouveau code de procédure
pénale du statut spécifique de la mise
en examen qui n'est pas une inculpation
nadarak il faut qu'il ya aujourd'hui un
couloir judiciaire il doit en quelque
sorte se dérouler dans la sérénité avec
le parler comme un stade
et puis un couloir politique ce couloir
politique
c'est celui du débat qu'il faut faire